I found this pole extremely disturbing
uh the Pew Research Center in Wall
Street NBC News did a poll on Americans
fear and civil liberties and the results
are not pretty let's they look
forty-seven percent of Americans right
now believe the u.s. is less safe than
it was before nine eleven up from twenty
eight percent last year that's a pretty
big jump almost twenty percent uh
concerns about protecting civil
liberties have dropped from 47 to
thirty-five percent so we're getting
more fearful and we don't care about our
rights as much sixty-two percent are
very concerned about the rise of Islamic
extremism around the world which is the
largest share dating back to 2007 I'm so
look we've done a bunch of stuff on Isis
on this show already so is everyone just
this goes to I think what you were
saying before is out there's Ebola in
the global warming and terror ever is
every like to meet us giving up our
civil rights is if I'm more afraid of
that than I am of all this external
stuff this is also the the work of the
mainstream media this is what they do
for a living have I mentioned that any
martial artist can tell you people are
manipulable when they are afraid and
angry and earlier we talked about the
anger component and this is the fear
component uh it is the job of the people
we listen to constantly we turn to them
for information and they sell us
antidepressants and in order to keep
selling as antidepressants they have to
keep telling us about how scary and
dangerous the world yeah by the way you
literally mean that I mean if you turn
on any of these new shows and after ad
and after and and I really assess every
time but i really wanted today should
have to show the people having the side
effects that they're you know when they
do the two-minute list of side effects
the person running through the field
shaking up I should [ __ ] their chance
[ __ ] [ __ ] big black oil spot in there
and write it yeah they just the guys
with his wife walking in front and just
turns and starts strangling the wife out
of nowhere that
and out jumps off the cliff brain just
explodes and blood dripping out of his
ear well sorry was it was a certain pops
open bees come flying out miss arrows uh
newbies the new bees knees let's put him
out there he's a helpful farm animal uh
yeah that the the whose pole was this by
the way so this is NBC news/wall Street
Journal uh with the pew research center
they do a lot of polls ah you're saying
there's a corporate interest here oh wow
how could there not be yeah just so it's
it's basically ask the people we need
you to ask about this so that we get a
62 on the fear about because I don't
know anyone that's scared [ __ ] about
this stuff and I know I know a few
people at my age yeah no one seems like
oh my main thing is I'm scared of
Islamic rising again you know we have
pummeled everything that they've done
previously why would that not be the
case this time when they rise again if
they take another two buildings down or
whatever they take do we not then
respond and just erase them it just
seems to make no sense that this is
happening in this order unless we have a
vested interest in a pony in the race
that's why I personally I fear the
internal stuff more than the external
stuff because when they knock down our
building guess they knocked on our
buildings and killed thousands people is
terrible but what did we do in response
to that we passed the Patriot Act which
then took away all right so imprisoning
other people had nothing to do with it
yes like the excuse to then lock us down
you know yeah be so you fear the
internal more to I think right this is
then then well I really what I got going
on internally is a terrifying man ya
know I I do I think I fear the the
erosion of civil rights I fear the slow
return to oppressive feudal society but
i think that the fear over civil rights
and the fear over Isis are all to
distract us from the fact that the the
wealth and the power is being slowly
consolidated away from us yeah and as
long as we're kept focused on these odd
little fears and and concerns and the we
won't be but we won't be fighting the
real tower that's the shiny hand that's
the busy hand
exactly right do you guys think the
Patriot Act's can go down is basically
the worst piece of legislation in
American history like that sort of set
the precedent for the reasons that we're
willing to give away all our rights in
the NSA and all that was ahead of
citizens united yeah it but I'd citizen
tonight might be neck and neck with it
yeah I think there have been some pretty
terrible pieces of legislation over the
years I don't I don't even want to start
to try to do a top ten list yeah fair
enough um is this why education is the
most important thing there is I mean
that's why why I try to do the show a
baby by silly of Education with the most
important thing there is we would be
investing money in it unless there was
some short corporation I was invested in
on PeopleSmart unless someone had a
vested interest in the ignorant yeah
that's right well I'd say it is it's
whatever your opponent on the chessboard
is trying to forbid from happening make
those things happen yeah whenever you
establish what they really want don't
let them have it like a riot you want to
write [ __ ] you know riot why [ __ ] you is
why [ __ ] your goals you're not important
enough [ __ ] drills [ __ ] [ __ ] you ghost
and [ __ ] you go Oh in front of a state
capital also down other the you know
they're they're fighting to put goats
everywhere into state capitols now but
I'd say that we are with we're now in an
Internet era of waking up in a different
way more and more people are not on that
NBC poll who are saying this is all
[ __ ] man and you know so of course
we won't get pulled yeah but I've never
been pulled for any of these things
you've ever ever i feel like i'm getting
pulled every day
there's I out